sprinting has a lot to do with power
it's a lot of being aggressive having
really powerful arms the shoulders are
really important because that's that's
what I'm doing this I have to do this
for 400 meters what I have found that's
contributed a lot to my success is an
underlying principle of rhythm it's this
thing that we say in practice it's kind
of like a dance
going into the final phase of an event
where you need to explode that's what
you want the comparison of being a
sprinter from able-bodied athlete to a
Paralympic athlete you know the major
thing is when you push out of the blocks
and you put your first step down you
know you're putting as much force as you
can in that moment but you have no
muscles pushing against you the first
five or six steps are hard to control
because you're not getting a lot out of
the foot and spreading the start is
crucial and if that's a whole race it's
pretty much off and so the angles of it
are really important something that I
learned how to do is get my angles
better driving out of the blocks
it's literally like an airplane it's a
gradual motion that you have to have
coming up out of the blocks long jump
somebody's running down the runway and
they explode off that left leg and
actually if you do it right you really
don't feel anything on your takeoff leg
body position in certain parts of the
race is really important when you get to
the critical zone it's things that
happen in that part of the race where
you pretty much just fall apart you see
people that try to finish like this
because of their bad as you start
decelerating the blade starts responding
a little bit differently so you don't
want to really maintain your posture
while you're entering into your
deceleration face so then you're not
wasting energy to cross the line unless
you kind of invest all this time in
training you don't have to work as hard
you just have to work smarter and just
have a little bit more quality rather
than quantity I love the challenge
nothing for me like getting to the end
of my race knowing that I'm the best in
the world is nothing like it